When I was told that the power of women is amazing, it was really impossible
to make Japanese sweets at home, which was the taste of my mother.
Why does it look like the second cut?
After all, I can't eat it like this, but it's gone, but it's gone. I
feel like I don't care about Japanese culture.
I mean,
[Music]
Japan was originally a professional in other play-cluster pitchers,
and about 70% of the people said that they don't want to be in the private women's airport.
I chose the Prince dish there for the 7th reason.
Par I was Japanese when I came to New York, but after all it looks like
Katy Nick Frost
American Western wasn't really longing for culture.  But maybe
it was about the 8th year that we came out p.
I think I'm starting to pay attention to that good glue Disney in
Japan here.  There were so many
, hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha.
I can't get 10 years, so I'm also a lecturer specializing in me, and I'm doing my best now.
[Music]
I'm doing it on my own. As a business, I'm
trying to spread sweets to 8 New York.
I told you that it's a cow, but it's a
little new at Kyokutei, so
everyone
from the staff to the
US staff When I brought what I made last night to the staff, everyone
was happy and the staff  From the call to ask if you would like to make dessert, the
start is that the taste of the housewife is okay.
That is the arch of the housewife.
[Music]
The following sentence is the taste of the housewife, so please do it.
Buber When the day in Japan opens, of course, this person at the hotel
is really a lot of paper in the world.  There is a Japanese producer in Japan.
Basically, all the housewives are
glampy and something like that. In Udu
[music]
, the guys'
teams get angry at the boy,
but maybe  I wasn't kicked because I was a woman like this
,
but I felt like I wasn't used to it near the city center
.
There are a lot of heavy tasks, but I don't leave that to me
first. After all, it
's a little Japan jealous Nemocchi
[Music]
pou dou dou
Moore
I think it's interesting.  I thought it was that much, and when I was away, I thought that the government was a woman
, and the
Cams were auto, then I saw them on foot, and after all, I was impressed with the
course.
Ah, there's something really different about America over there. It's cool
. New York is different from Japan
.
Yeah
me.
Confectionery is really Japan's representative food,
Elkadu.  It
says that Japanese confectionery is a button for individual food, but you can see it, see it, hear it, hear it,
taste it, and
touch it with your tactile sensation.
I don't
think
it's beautiful,
so I think Japan doesn't have all the Japanese sweets and shapes.
[Music] The
death penalty is the most ceremonial seeds.
Look at the sweets and see the cherry blossoms at the end Ah,
it's a public person, isn't it? It's about
time for Chris to wait for Chris.
I'm making it
[Music] When
I started to think about it and thought about what I could do there, it was
the dusk of the Japanese I knew on the spot.
Well, it's kind of like a meeting mission right now. I think it's
probably more of a Japanese ingredient if it's received by an American.
I wish I could spread coffee to everyone more
me
me The
West Festival that came with the full price today That play
cheek suit Himura still I've been working while thinking that I want to do something that suits
me  Sometimes it overlaps, I
think it's really fate, I think it's really a year, and
I started the input marathon myself and completed it for 5 years.
The shins of sugar and small beans are
natural materials, so even if you eat them, they will be absorbed immediately and become energy.
I think that's what I think. Japanese sweets made at home are
eaten by mother's judges.
Well, women and men, and
professionals, and
I've always made very mothers.
It ’s mothers, but what ’s that
? After all, it ’s like this
.
You can express what you want to
do, such as that thing. You can see women from different parts of what you see from those craftsmen,
so it's
kind of like a circus or something like that.  It's not a subtle thing to
be with, but if you can teamate with the edge, you can entertain with your mouth or work, but
it feels like something that only God remains in that heart
.